hey guys i'm kamna you can find me on
instagram at connorvospherin and i share
south asian inspired tips recipes and
hacks to make life easier some people
think indian cooking can be complicated
and i can understand why when you see
the recipe list it's usually this long
that's why today i'm gonna be making
three five ingredient indian desserts so
let's get started so the first recipe
i'm going to be showing you today is
mango kolpi mango kofi is a traditional
indian ice cream and what makes it
different than american ice cream is
that it's made without air so it has a
richer creamier denser taste to get
started we're going to bloom our saffron
saffron
is one of my favorite ingredients
because it's found in a lot of
traditional indian cooking and it's also
a really powerful antioxidant so i'm
going to put in about a pinch that's
about 10 to 15 strands and add in about
a tablespoon of hot water so adding a
tablespoon of hot water to your pinch of
saffron really helps extract that flavor
from the saffron and saffron can be a
little pricey so this gives you a little
bit more bang for your buck i'm gonna
set this aside for about five minutes
just to let these flavors really get
extracted now that my saffron is off to
the side i'm gonna show you how i crush
fresh cardamom and all i do is i take
the cardamom out of the pod
remove the shell and just make sure that
you get all the black seeds out put them
into your mortar and pestle and then you
just give it a nice pound
that looks great i'm going to set that
aside and now get started on our whipped
cream
so now i'm gonna add my heavy cream so
this has been chilled a bit and i'm
adding it to the bowl and i'm gonna whip
it until i get a nice soft peace
now i'm ready to add the rest of my
ingredients so first thing is half a can
of sweetened condensed milk you want to
just gently fold that in to
the heavy whipping cream now i'm adding
my mango caser so this is canned mango
pulp i get from the indian store you can
use fresh alfonso mango if you can find
it but if you use canned mango pulp
that's completely fine too and now
you'll see it turn that beautiful orange
color that's signature to mango cool add
in my ground cardamom and my saffron
with the water
get that a gentle nice mix
once you get this mixed and nice and
incorporated we're gonna add it to our
bowl it looks so beautiful love that
color that's exactly the color we were
looking for i'm gonna cover this and pop
it in the freezer and let this freeze
for about eight hours or overnight so
this is what the coffee should look like
coming out of the freezer it's gotten
nice and hard but it'll still have that
signature creamy texture now we're ready
to dig in and scoop it out and i love
seeing the saffron the cardamom and look
at that rich
orange mango color
and now i'm just going to sprinkle it
with a little bit of rose petal a little
bit of saffron just to give it a little
pretty look there we go mango coffee i
cannot wait to try this
that mango just brings back so many
memories of summers in india the mango
just shines in this recipe it goes so
well with the saffron and the cardamom
honestly i think this is the best batch
of coffee i've ever made so next we'll
be making coconut ladoos coconut ladoos
are like a little ball of joy we have
these for the bali the indian new year
good night's short these celebrations
and i also use coconut ladoos and
instead of holiday cookies i give these
to my friends during christmas and they
love them because they're just so
different and they taste so good so the
first step that we're gonna do is we're
gonna add desiccated coconut desiccated
coconut is coconut that has the air and
the moisture has been taken out of the
coconut and all that remains is the
spine powder now if you don't have
desiccated coconut you can just take
dried coconut flakes put them in the
food processor and get this nice
desiccated coconut powder i'm using an
insta pot right now you can use your
stove as well but what we're going to do
is we're going to add this to a little
bit of low heat to get these nice and
toasty the only thing you really have to
remember when you are putting in your
coconut is you just have to keep
stirring because you don't want any part
of it to burn did you can almost feel
that it's become a little bit crispier
and just turns a tiny bit of light brown
now we're gonna add our sweetened
condensed milk and you just put it right
in mix it right in remember to turn your
heat off
and you just mix this together now what
i love is you don't have to be too
gentle you really have to use muscle to
just get it all mixed in and you can
already see a dough forming
and now you're going to add your
cardamom it really just elevates this
dough wakes it up this recipe you don't
have to be too gentle you don't have to
worry about messing up and so there's
really nothing that can go wrong here
which is why i love it it's kind of like
my fail proof
dessert and see
now this is how the dough should look
the only thing is is that the dough
right now it's a little too soft so i'm
going to put this in the fridge for
about five minutes just so it gets
hardened and it's easier to work with
this is the dough out of the fridge and
you can see that it has hardened a lot
and now we're gonna do my favorite part
which is making our laddu balls so i
take about a golf ball size and i just
roll it in my hands i can feel it
sticking just a bit so i'm going to show
you guys a little hack i put a little
bit of ghee or a little bit of coconut
oil on my hands and that way the dough
doesn't stick to my hands i take this
ball here you don't have to make it
perfect just want to get it into a nice
little round ball and then this is what
i like to do i roll it in a bit of
shredded coconut just to give it a nice
beautiful little texture here and there
you go these are my ladies you can kind
of stack them and plate them how you
like you can see they have this
beautiful round shape but what i'm going
to do is i'm going to put them in the
fridge for another three three to five
minutes just so they harden up and they
really hold that shape and i'm going to
check back in and what i like to do is
at the very end i take a little bit of
crushed pistachio and i just sprinkle it
all over the top and there you go
coconut ladies with five ingredients
oh my gosh
and what i love is that these really
have that authentic indian taste people
will think you spent hours making these
but they were so easy to make for this
last recipe we're going to be making
saffron shrikhand mousse shrikhand is a
dish found in the western states of
india it's typically served at weddings
or you can even use shrikhand as a side
dish because it really complements kind
of spicy indian food where you want a
little bit of yogurt to cool it down so
first thing you have to remember to hang
your yogurt what you do is you take a
strainer and you put it over a bowl this
bowl is going to collect the excess
liquid or the whey from your yogurt and
then you take a cheesecloth or a piece
of muslin cloth and put it over your
strainer just like this and now you're
going to add your yogurt i'm going to
put that right into the cheesecloth next
we're going to wrap this up
and what you want to do is just create a
little ball and just give it a nice
little twist i can already see some of
the liquid or that whey is kind of
coming out and that's exactly what we
want i'm just going to let this sit in
the fridge for about six to eight hours
i like to do overnight that way i know
all that whey has separated from the
yogurt this is what the yogurt looks
like after you've kept it in the fridge
overnight and you can see that kind of
liquid that whey has drained out from
the yogurt you can keep the way if you
want to i know some people use this in
their smoothies i personally just
discard it but do whatever you like i
just love to see this part how it looks
oh that looks so beautiful look at that
it's a lot thicker a lot harder it
almost looks like a dough so i have my
hung curd and i put it right into my
bowl now i'm going to add one cup of
powdered sugar i've got my silk saffron
just like i did in my kulfi recipe we're
going to add it right to the mixture
with the water and the last thing is
we're going to add in our ground
cardamom and we're just going to mix
these together but you really do have to
use a little bit of mussel because that
yogurt is kind of stiff perfect this is
exactly how i want it to look at this
point it's pretty much done you can see
it has this really velvety nice creamy
texture with a little taste
perfect and now all you have to do is
transfer it to your serving dishes what
i like to do is i like to top with a
little whipped cream and crushed nuts at
the end this is optional but my nanny
always told me my grandma always told me
the best part about making indian
desserts is to make them your own
sprinkles sprinkle with just a little
bit of fresh nuts and there you go five
ingredients saffron shrikhand mousse
this tastes so silky you can taste the
cardamom that saffron really just
married so well together this tastes
like the perfect sunday afternoon
dessert and there you go three five
ingredient indian desserts first we made
our mango kofi then our coconut ladoos
and finally our saffron shrikhand mousse
i cannot wait for you guys to try this
and let me know what your favorite is in
the comments below
yay
oh yes
[Music]
[Applause]
you